what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and it's finally here
the moment that we've all been waiting
for for over
three years dobby has finally confirmed
his true identity to the world
and i don't think that many of us were
surprised after all this time
but the way that dobby revealed the
truth and the implications of that
reveal on the entire hero society
were absolutely game changing this was
so freaking
epic one of the best chapters in all of
mha
so let's get into it if you enjoy our
boku no hero videos and you want us to
keep it going
please leave a like and drop a comment
on this video
you might think that it doesn't matter
but it actually matters a lot
every single like and comment tells the
youtube algorithm to promote this video
to more people
so every time you like and comment you
are directly supporting this channel
and if you want to see us live react to
crazy chapters like this one be sure to
follow us on twitch
live reacting to this dobby reveal with
hundreds of you guys in the chat was
absolutely awesome so check us out on
twitch twitch.tv slash
anime uproar finally this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
this long awaited chapter is called
dobby's dance
and you just know that once this is
animated dobby will become the new
fan cam king sorry k-pop stars your time
is done
honestly though this chapter was insane
as soon as the leaks dropped dobby was
trending globally
on social media and as soon as we saw
the leaks
my editor dakota broski and i fangirled
about them for
quite a while check out dakota by the
way he's awesome and his link is in the
description now when i say that this
revealable dobby's true identity has
been a long time coming i really mean it
we waited for this moment for literal
years and for
hundreds of manga chapters i went back
and checked and my first video
about the theory that dabi is
toyatodoroki was published on september
29th
of 2017. that was over three years ago
and i wasn't even the first to talk
about the theory people were speculating
about it on reddit and other platforms
months before i published that video so
yeah
this has been some journey but here we
are and the single most popular boku no
hero fan theory has just been confirmed
this historic chapter starts off inside
the psychiatric institution where
shoto's mother ray todoroki is currently
staying
as you will recall she ended up in this
institution as a result of all the abuse
that she suffered at the hands of her
husband angie
also known as endeavour rey is watching
what looks like a random news broadcast
in her
room but suddenly the broadcast is
interrupted
it turns out that dobby has been
watching rey from afar for some time
and now rey sees a pre-recorded
broadcast of
dobby as a confused rey looks at the
screen
the focus of the chapter switches back
to the main battlefield
as we know makia has finally arrived on
the battlefield in order to help
shigaraki
and all for one is very grateful for
makia's timing
all for one knows that shigaraki is
vulnerable right now and he's been
trying to tell him to back off and rest
but shiguraki's been ignoring his former
master all for one is surprised that
shigaki's body hasn't already collapsed
by now
apparently all for one has been trying
to help him by using a mutant quirk
within his spine to minimize the damage
that he has been sustaining but even so
shigaraki is in trouble from what it
sounds like his
body could literally break down at any
time
and all for one is hoping that he can
order machia to force shigaraki to
retreat
and recuperate but we already know that
shigaraki doesn't want to retreat
so even if all for one gives the order
the question is
which master will machia obey he now
considers both of them to be his masters
so i wonder what will happen when his
two masters are giving him
two conflicting orders by the way i
thought that little detail about the
mutant quirk in shigaraki's spine was
pretty interesting this must be
another quirk that shigaraki received
from all for one
and i really wonder how it works does it
make his spine more
flexible allowing it to absorb more
damage
or does it alter the body in some other
way
there has to be some explanation for
shigeraki's insane
physical resilience but we'll have to
wait and see the heroes know that they
are in big trouble
now that makia has arrived shoto
believes that they must take advantage
of shigaraki's vulnerability and take
him out
before makia can reach him so he and
nejira desperately try to tag team
shigaraki
negire unleashes her waves and shoto
releases both his flames
and ice all at the same time but before
these attacks can take shigaraki out
maki arrives and protects him with his
giant hand
and nejir and shoto barely managed to
escape getting flattened by makia
meanwhile bakugo has regained
consciousness
after sustaining that injury in the
fight against shigaraki
so i guess nakstaku is not a prophet
after all
at least not yet in classic kachon style
bakugo wants to rejoin the fight despite
his severe injury
ida tells him that he must retreat and
get medical help but is bakugo going to
listen
of course not in that sense bakugou is
as
bad as deku after making sure that shoto
and deku are okay
endeavor turns his attention to machia
endeavour is determined to find a way to
stop machia
but the problem is that endeavour is not
operating at full power
in fact it seems that his body has been
so damaged by the overuse of his quirk
that he is barely breathing
and one of his lungs may have actually
collapsed
but even though he is facing some very
difficult odds
endeavour feels the burden of being the
number one pro
hero all of japan is counting on him to
protect them from the villains
and endeavour is determined to live up
to those expectations
he is determined to take machia down
however in that very moment dobby
makes his appearance he calls out to the
heroes from a top of machia
and he is clearly pleased that both
endeavour and shoto
are there in the same place endeavour
and the others didn't realize that makia
was carrying more villains on his back
and when he does see him endeavour calls
out
dobby's name but dobby then does
something so freaking epic
he asks endeavor why he's calling him by
his villain moniker
instead of by his real name dobby then
uses some sort of cleaning solution to
wash
off the black dye in his hair
i'm not sure if this was just water or
something stronger but at any rate it is
revealed that beneath the black dye
dobby's hair is actually white
and in that same panel which reveals the
true color of dobby's hair
dobby also reveals that his real name is
of course toya
todoroki no one saw this coming
seriously though we all saw it coming
but more on that later
at first i was a bit confused about the
white hair part because
in the anime toya was shown to have red
hair
but i guess that might have been a
mistake that the anime studio
made still i did think that dobby having
red hair just like endeavour would be a
nice touch since it would make perfect
sense for him to want to hide his true
hair color because he hates his father
that said i can totally live with the
white hair
after all toya's mother rey has white
hair and most of his siblings have
predominantly white hair
as well as dabi reveals his real name
everyone seems genuinely shocked and
this includes endeavor
and shoto so it really doesn't seem like
either of them
actually knew that dobby was toyah i'm
not sure if they believed that toya was
dead
or if he just like ran away from home or
if he was given up to a boarding school
or something
but for those of you who thought that
endeavour secretly knew about dobby's
identity and was just trying to hide it
from the world
it really doesn't seem like it we then
get a peek
at the pre-recorded broadcast that
todoroki played for his mother rey
although skeptic is helping to broadcast
this to the general public as well
dobby explains that he is toya todoroki
the eldest son of endeavor
and that he is a villain who has
murdered over 30
innocent people dobby blames the number
one pro hero endeavor
for his crimes explaining that behind
the scenes
endeavor has always been cruel and power
hungry
for many years endeavor was obsessed
with surpassing
all might and when he realized that he
won't be able to do it on his own
he decided to groom a successor who
would one day overtake
the symbol of peace in order to
accomplish this
endeavor forcibly took on a wife with a
powerful quirk
he didn't marry her for love and he
didn't have children because he wanted
to be a caring father
all he wanted was to have a child who
was born with a quirk that is
even more powerful than all mites
everything endeavour did
he did for power and for achieving his
own
selfish dream but dobby the firstborn
son was considered a failure
by endeavor he didn't have the
qualifications necessary for surpassing
all might and as a result dabi was
abandoned
he was tossed aside and forgotten by his
own
father i am not sure what exactly dobby
means by abandoned here
was dabi actually forced to leave the
family home
or was he just neglected by endeavour in
favor of shoto
we still don't know the exact details of
how it all went down between endeavor
and toya
but i'm sure that those details will be
revealed in the coming chapters
dobby explains that he has never
forgotten what endeavor did to him
and he has been following endeavour's
career from afar
dabi's fire the fire that has burned
dozens of innocent people to death
is endeavour's own fire this is highly
symbolic of course
and on the battlefield itself dobby then
reveals to endeavor
that his life story is being broadcast
to all of japan
at this very moment meaning that
endeavour's reputation as the number one
pro hero
has already been ruined now while i
definitely think that criticizing
endeavor is fair here
dobby can't blame endeavour for his
decision to murder
all of those people at the end of the
day dobby is an adult now
and he made his own decisions
endeavour's cruelty towards him
doesn't justify his own cruelty towards
other
innocent people but with that said
dobby's narrative here
is definitely a very effective way to
tarnish endeavour's reputation as a hero
which is exactly what he wants dobby
explains that for years he has been
waiting for the perfect way to destroy
endeavour's career and enact his revenge
as a child toya was devastated by his
father's rejection
and abandonment and he cried every day
asking his brother natsu why he was even
born
in the first place he felt worthless and
he grew envious of his brother shoto
shoto was father's favorite he was
endeavour's big project
and toya was treated like garbage
treated like he was a failure
initially dobby was planning on killing
shoto once
shoto became famous in order to crush
endeavour's dream
of raising the successor of all might
but when endeavour
unexpectedly became the number one pro
hero after
all might's retirement dobby decided to
change his plans
instead of killing shoto he would
destroy endeavour just as he hit
the height of his fame he would destroy
endeavour's reputation
just as he finally achieved his lifelong
dream of becoming the number one
pro hero dobby can tell that since
becoming the number one pro hero
endeavor has been trying to change this
responsibility of being the top pro hero
and all the glory that comes with it
have definitely changed
endeavor he is no longer obsessed with
surpassing all might
so now he is actually trying to be a
better person and a better father to his
other children endeavor is looking
forward and trying to move beyond his
abusive past
but dobby is here to make sure that
endeavour cannot
escape his past endeavour can't simply
move on with his life
and act like nothing happened after all
endeavor never publicly acknowledged
what he has done to his family he never
owned up to what he did he might be
trying to be a better person now
but that doesn't change what he has
already done and dabi is here to make
sure that endeavor finally faces the
consequences of his actions
once and for all the chapter ends with
the words
let us fall together ng todoroki
come dance with your son in hell and
wow what a moment this is not just for
this
arc but for the entire boku no hero
series
definitely one of the best chapters in
mha
and one of the most anticipated moments
in the modern history of manga we all
knew that this twist was coming
at this point we would have been more
surprised if dobby wasn't
toyah but even though this was expected
it was still an incredibly
impactful moment and the specific way in
which
dobby made the reveal was absolutely
amazing
not only was it a dramatic personal
moment for endeavor and shoto as dabi
made the reveal to them in person
but thanks to the public broadcast this
reveal
instantly became a national issue
everyone in japan just learned
the dark truth about the number one pro
hero
and endeavour's reputation is ruined
just when japan
needs a symbol of peace the most just
when they desperately need to have faith
in the heroes and in the number one pro
hero in particular
dabi has managed to completely discredit
endeavor and along with him
dobby has discredited the entire hero
system the whole hero society and
that is exactly what the league of
villains has been trying to do
all along they've been trying to bring
the hero society to its knees
dobby's reveal about endeavor will be
just as effective
in eroding trust in the hero society as
the biggest and most destructive
villain attacks and that is especially
the case now
in a moment of chaos and uncertainty
when trust in the hero society must be
at an
all-time low we all remember when
horikoshi was criticized for giving
endeavor
a sort of redemption arc but hurt people
mostly on twitter because that's where
butthurt people live
were upset that horikoshi was humanizing
endeavor
but of course endeavour is human and it
is perfectly normal for humans to try to
change and move
past their mistakes however in this
chapter dobby demonstrates that finding
redemption will not be so
simple for endeavor endeavour can't just
decide to become a better person and
move beyond his past mistakes
without first owning up and taking
responsibility
for those mistakes in this chapter dobby
exposes
endeavors hypocrisy he wants redemption
without the inconvenience of admitting
his mistakes and facing the consequences
of those mistakes
in front of the entire population dobby
just made sure that endeavour
is going to have to face all of his
mistakes head on
and that is exactly what horikoshi had
planned from the very beginning
horikoshi was never planning to just let
endeavour off the hook for what he has
done
he was always planning to have endeavour
faced with the past
in the form of dobby so everyone who
criticized
horikoshi for endeavour's development
clearly jumped the shark and had no idea
what they were talking about
but what else is new on twitter anyway
this chapter is
only the beginning of the todoroki
family drama
dobby just opened pandora's box but
there is still a lot that we don't know
about what exactly happened with
endeavour and dobby
and we still don't know how dobby went
from a neglected child
to a sadistic villain i can't wait to
learn more about all of this
in the coming chapters and i can't wait
to see the impact of this massive reveal
on the wider hero society let me know
what you guys think did you love this
chapter as much as i did and how do you
feel
now that this old and massively popular
fan theory has finally been
confirmed what happens next between
endeavour and
dobby and what happens to shoto and
finally
how will this reveal affect the rest of
the big showdown
in jakku don't forget to share your
thoughts down in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more boku no hero content
right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime outpour or
maybe you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you want to be
there for our live reactions to the
latest leaks
and spoilers don't forget to follow us
on twitch twitch.tv
slash anime uproar i want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible a special thank you to alpha
sigma
disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect liam thompson
pate heffa red-haired raven emperor
otaku
thomas jones and spidey life tinnell
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky cricket xp joe stanton
rathuen de ora very gucci jessica kayla
fond alicia ochter hinokami in water
bonnie parks florian joanne garcia
deadly saint high school dxd 73
baked buddhist matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you